hello and thank you for being with us
let's bring you some breaking news this
lunch time a next-generation vaccine for
coronavirus has been approved by the uk
medicines regulator the adapted covid
vaccine made by moderna targets two
different variants the original virus
from 2020 and the omicron variant that
was the first of its kind to be approved
for use anywhere in the world let's get
more on this by bringing in our science
and medical correspondence thomas more a
good afternoon to you thomas so this is
big news from madonna that they've
managed to get this vaccine cleared
through
yes this is approval by the uk medical
regulator that shows that this
two-pronged approach to
covid's that the vaccine is safe and
effective
based on the trial data so far it
elicits a strong immune response
to omicron and we know from the existing
vaccine against the original covid virus
that it was less effective against
omicron and that has resulted in
increasing levels of disease still
protecting uh to a very large extent
against hospital hospitalization and
serious disease but still allowing
people particularly to become reinfected
and that has been a an issue which has
uh led to multiple uh waves of omicron
over recent months now the hope is that
by having a two-pronged approach that
this vaccine contains elements of both
the original covid uh virus but also
some from omicron 2 that you would be
able to protect people much
more effectively going into the autumn
period you'll be you'll remember that
the the government has announced that
there will be an autumn booster campaign
for everyone over the age of 50 and
those with underlying health conditions
and carers too so this is something
which is uh all likely to become part of
a feature of the uk but it still needs
to be approved by the joint committee of
vaccination uh and immunization uh they
will look at this data see whether it's
worth swapping from the old vaccine to
this new one as indeed the european
commission has already done uh modern
has reached an agreement with them to
swap over existing contracts to this new
vaccine uh if it is approved by their
medical authority so it does seem that
it will only be a matter of time uh
before this vaccine does become uh
routine for the uk and it's both worth
saying too that pfizer which is the
other vaccine which has been used to a
great extent and as part of the booster
program they too are working on a very
similar vaccine fantastic stuff all
right thomas uh more from you i'm sure
throughout the day thank you for that
for now